at the lab factory there was a guy that
was doing like airplane jokes and and
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that and i went up
after and i said i think we need to find
a black box on his act
[Laughter]
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg
millions of people have already
downloaded the dave app to get the
financial relief they need with extra
cash so if you're in a pinch and need
some extra help download dave and think
of it as a helping hand
from future you
download the dave app from the app store
right now that's d-a-v-e
sign up for an extra cash account and
get up to 500 dollars instantly for
terms and conditions go to dave.com
legal instant transfer fees apply
banking provided by evolve
member remember fdic
future you will thank you
hey everybody this is producer grant
here just a reminder if you like the
show if you're enjoying the show please
like comment subscribe on any platform
you're checking it out on whether that's
on youtube whether that's apple podcast
spotify anything any engagement that we
have really really helps we all serve
the almighty algorithm these days and
any amount that you sort of interact
with the show in any way just really
helps us out helps us get cooler guests
for the show helps raise the profile for
the show helps give us more content for
you guys to enjoy so thanks again for
checking it out and please enjoy the
episode of all the hormones that we've
had in here
[Laughter]
the the invisible man is back
good to be here he cut his hair they
[ __ ] it up he said i'm gonna wait till
it grows out before i go back but
uh the our guest today
is i've always found one of the most
intriguing people that
that i've met along my journey of comedy
because
a lot of latino a lot of latinos when
they look at options for their careers
in stand-up only want to do stand-up
because you have to be of other skills
to be able to be
an actor
to be able to be a writer to be able to
perform sketches and to be able to do
stand-up and do dramatic and do
everything
um
so a lot of guys
that come from backgrounds where
you're just looking for
a ladder the first rung you're not
looking for four wrongs you're just
trying to get on and try to climb the
ladder
but when i started to see frankie
quinones i thought that's a very
different approach because
charlie chaplin did different characters
very rarely did he do stuff that he was
by himself but cantinflas did stuff that
was like i think the stuff that frankie
does like it so
resonates with um the culture that
even latinos i mean the same thing
happened with the churro it was so good
there was no way that you could degrade
a [ __ ] judo or degrade
like if a white person be like this is
friend i've never thought
of putting mayonnaise on a corn but i
love it
so this is like the churros of comedy
like he can never
not ups he can't he can't upset anyone
it's so real and it's so from total fit
to the whistle
to el chicano i i was in el chicana to
play the lieutenant and i know
that this guy was in el chicano and the
movie was more dramatic so they had to
remove frankie because frankie was so
funny that it didn't fit
what the detectives were doing
not that it didn't not that his
performance was it was too good
because he went up to the car and he
started talking to the cops but he was
so funny
that if they had left it in the movie it
would have
it would have changed the
the dynamic of those guys because those
guys were on it they ended up having a
big fight and it had to go because it
just
you can't be laughing and then go what
the [ __ ] yeah where'd that guy go
so but but dramatic and funny and really
hold the attention of of the screen
which very few um uh people can do so
um we'll get to all that i don't know
where he's from i don't know
um anything about his upbringing all i
would say in in
if i were to give you any advice nobody
asked me for the [ __ ] what do i know
nobody ever asked me for a [ __ ]
advice you're so shy listen everybody
everybody uh want me to walk you out to
my walk of fame my star on the sidewalk
and we can go over there where you
caught the [ __ ] the nightstalker over
there in the neighborhood did we make it
out
the um
um
then the 20 years that my show has been
on it's still on it still is let's see
if your documentary is out of 20 years
i won't be here in 20 years won't give a
[ __ ]
well
uh i hope you would live in john have a
good time in heaven
[Music]
there we go frankie welcome to the
podcast oh thank you man yeah and on
your way out could you trim that thing
behind you i'm kidding
no no no uh yes
what was the first time that you saw
frankie [ __ ] king of comedy over here
i i saw him on the on
on the internet this cholo stuff going
back to where my beginnings were
you know at age 17 they took me home
said get him off street sign for me end
up in prison or dead
then to become a cop then to specialize
in gangs then to see you
uh i can't stop live my family
was more excited about me coming down
here today because i was gonna he was
gonna be the guest now grant then then
anybody i didn't tell them grant was
gonna that's a surprise for later yeah
with the hair how about your dog is your
dog still happy to see my dog's still
happy to see me brother
but my family was so excited about
coming down here because i was gonna be
with you oh we're gonna be again oh i'm
serious no no no did you ever have to
bust any of your old homies or your
family or no i i saw him in custody and
then we did some stuff together because
i didn't have to hook i didn't actually
have to hook up not one of my uh oh can
you let somebody go
not you but can a police officer let
somebody go
that that he pulls over i mean not if
not for a misdemeanor i'm sure not for a
felony because then you become part of
the family but but for a misdemeanor
somebody saw the radio and you said hey
just put the radio back
ah no if they commit a crime traffic
violations yes you know it's all
discretionary
and misdemeanors depending on where they
happen how they happen you know
you don't have to arrest for misdemeanor
not committed in your presence
but felonies yes everybody goes you know
in the uh
70s and 80s i'm sure maybe it still
happens not probably not so much anymore
before phones
uh
allegedly police would pull over uh
women that they thought were attractive
oh sure and try to get their information
try to get their phone number or
talk them uh you know sure
dirty dogs
i had a girlfriend that got that got
pulled over by the cop and the cop made
a move on her he saw her went around put
the lights on
um
uh sometimes the girls would play into
it like they would let
a nipple come out you know like a little
like a little like like you know 6 30 in
the morning just starting to come out
that's the only time i stopped women
and i'll tell you what not to do i got
pulled over one time and i pulled my
daddy out don't do that
but uh there are cops that went to
prison for that [ __ ] george there's a
whole idea behind bad lieutenant
remember harvey keitel the battle
lieutenant oh yeah yeah yeah i remember
that this is a good lieutenant here bro
man when when uh when you when you went
to vietnam did did they play comedy
albums back then would they have
a record player of vietnam i remember
they had uh not on not on that we had
the armed forces television so he showed
the same program over and over and over
again uh
the big one was uh
[ __ ] combat and then there was a funny
program they showed you combat yeah
and it was a joke okay
yeah big moral combat
there was a funny one
doktori with a cross-eyed land there
there was a comedy show that was on for
you uh
ruth buzzy used to come on you know
um
laughing laughing laughing was a big big
show over there you know i remember
watching laughing that was pretty good
it was it was a good show they did stuff
they got political and laughing they got
they did anything they wanted to they
got political they did you know uh all
the big goldie hawn all the big stars
political that was a show where
political i think richard nixon was on
there
sparrow agnew
all the young actresses and all the
great comedians were there it was great
relief for guys vietnam i loved it
really an amazing show man like you
don't know if you would ever see a show
like that again because it had political
figures both democrats and republicans i
don't think there were any independents
back then but yeah it was great i didn't
care if we saw two three days in a row
it was relief from what we and where did
your love of comedy come from
just my love of laughter since i was a
kid my mom my mom
you know if you didn't shut up thank god
you were probably in the helicopter
because with that laugh the chinese
i remember in boot camp i got in trouble
because this guy this uh a new d.i came
in and he's walking around you know
smokey the bear hat he's got a little
swagger stick he's telling us you know
i'll be your mother i'll be your father
i'll be your
wife the only thing the only different
thing me and your girlfriend is i'm
gonna [ __ ] you you're not gonna [ __ ] me
yep and i started laughing
i thought it was funny and he comes up
and he says hey maggie you're yelling am
i you think something funny sir i
thought that last
comment you made about [ __ ]
you [ __ ] us was funny sir
and he says oh you did and he got behind
me and he kicked me dead in the ass
dead in the ass launched me forward i
hit the [ __ ] ground it was his foot
it was his foot though
[Laughter]
i stopped it some more
no he knocked me and i [ __ ] laughed
when i hit the ground
and he got up and then he said you think
it's funny yeah get outside and he made
me run around with a rifle above my head
i will not laugh i should not laugh and
make me start running around the berry
well after a couple of times around it
wasn't funny anymore
but it's
even the departmental shrink one time
told me you know i couldn't stop
laughing at her
and she's so as uh as government
property they can put their hands on you
you can't [ __ ] i don't know if they
could or couldn't i was i was a
at that time i was a 17 year old
guy in boot camp nobody would have
thought of finally complaining about no
drill instructor no no no no
the departmental shrink
told me that uh
she was
after the cerritos air disaster where
the idaho vehicle
so i had to go out there for two days
help picking parts so i'm out there and
then right after they give you a
debriefing and we had this new
uh doctor from psychological services
made us all get together for a
debriefing and she says you're probably
wondering why i'm making a mandatory we
all come and talk to you here
says well it's because after san diego
disaster we found out that
two months three months six months later
people were having problems they didn't
know what it was and they found out it
was all related to what they had gone
through with the air disaster
so you never know when that funny
feeling is going to come about
and you know it could hit you any time
and i'm just letting you know we're here
to help you
what do you think is behind the ptsd you
think you think it's the shock
of seeing something that you're not used
to seeing right or or the amount of time
that you have to see something i don't
know i don't know
because maybe you know because when
you're a doctor you can see again you
can open people and when you're a
traffic cop you see things that are
um
you know scientifically there's it's
like a doctor it's scientific to you i
saw i saw a video on youtube of a of a
woman that was driving drunk
and
her face was hanging off
so her it was moved to the side and her
eye was moving but her face was
completely off
and she was in the back seat and guys
when people were looking at her and
trying to tell her to calm down
and and i
you know i couldn't look at it but she
was still alive and she really kind of
didn't know which was a drunk driving
and didn't really know what was going on
but i'd never seen an injury that bad on
a human being that was that was still
alive
she was [ __ ] up and she was [ __ ]
shocked
should i get up in the eye brother do my
eyebrows
but i mean you know some people could
get ptsd of that but if they prepare you
for things then
i mean i think combat is different but
i think that's what they were trying to
do prepare us for for stuff like that
and i just chuckled and she says
what's wrong and i said and this is
before you had to be politically correct
and i could tell you right now i i still
remember what she was wearing she was
all dressed in red including her red
pumps
no but she had everything else was right
they were they were appropriate oh and
so i just looked at her
and she says yes can i help me i breathe
my hands she's going to help me and i
said yeah
and i looked down from her feet and went
all the way up i said i think i'm
getting that funny feeling right now
and the whole the whole class started
laughing she started weinstein
everybody started laughing
she turned beat red
and she says
okay i get it and everybody laughed
everything was always funny to me how
about
how about those were they hey
pop those out sister everybody
like the peanuts they're all laughing
and yelling dogs dancing on the thing
uh but uh
um
it's the same thing to me
as being a battered husband listen i
mean there's dudes out there that are
battered husbands you know
i'll cut the grass tomorrow all right um
the the inspiration for
no so let's let's see wh where did you
grow up and where were you born
i was born in san fernando yeah yeah so
you're born at several hospital at
um holy cross you know the well well
michigan hills i technically yeah oh
[ __ ] i don't do i'm from michigan
i was born in the same hospital as
george lopez and she said really she
goes yeah it must be there's only that
one and that's all across yeah so yeah
did you guys live there no we lived in a
a chatsworth you know a one-bedroom
apartment there but i was still young we
moved to oxford and then and then and
then camarillo i went to high school in
ventura listen when you're born and you
live out there in chatsworth and you're
going to holy cross the water's already
dry it might have broke but it's already
dry
the lake's dry the whole water my water
broke when three hours ago get them in
here yeah it already cut brackets
already coming out
[Music]
um
but i i didn't know well i guess they do
have a maternity uh thing there yeah
yeah they do yeah it was a smaller
hospital in the 71 in the earthquake
that that hospital and then the one in
sylmar
suffered nothing down nothing was uh
earthquake retrofitting yeah and then
who and and who in your family
um was any any musicians or or any
performers or any no man my mom you know
my mom and dad were just they're still
married now they had me at a young age
so we're still pretty close but uh but
mike my abuelito he's like the biggest
piazza that i know he's still to this
day he's 95 just turned 95 i mean he
still gets up you know cracks his little
joke story tiles and then sits back down
what kind of jokes what kind of little
jokes does he crack you know just
telling talent he likes to tell stories
you know and he's just funny about it
you know about his days back when he was
in sacategas and then when they him and
his brothers they came here to or to
pacoima but then my grandpa went to
oxford because he was like to go work
and agriculture you know he's packing
yeah yeah
you know what it worked in the world i
was packing lemons on the trains and all
that strawberries and yeah yeah
those are the days
did you ever pick any crops or anything
i didn't pick not even my nose brother i
was in the city i didn't go out it
doesn't matter anybody that does that is
they're here
because they're feeding this country
people really appreciate it
the uh
my joke was you know that
um
uh
when you when you work all week
and you're picking lettuce you know some
people say work for food you work all
week picking lettuce you're not going to
make yourself a salad on saturday
that was like a full thought she's not
working on mondays where it puts a vegan
or corn flakes hey i'm off today
uh um
and and uh what were you watching when
you were growing up like what were the
cheech and chong and stuff like that oh
yeah man of course like you know you
know the the the the cheese i watched
all the cheech and chong videos i
watched uh you know my mom and dad would
like watch stand up yeah you know
religiously and then we watched a living
color right culture clash when that was
on so so that you guys got into like the
character stuff like the guy the culture
class guys were doing and lemon color
was
different right because most of them we
were trying to live yeah when it was
good yeah and i would i would do i got a
sprinkler head for my dad's work truck
and i use it as a microphone i started
doing little shows for them when i was
little you know and they would kind of
get annoying
that's
that's beautiful that's great yeah you
got the jeans put a little put a little
sprinkler head are you on haws on it
w-h-a-w-e-s
the sprinkler and uh uh and you made we
had voices and all that stuff you did
voices and yeah just i was into like the
characters
because you know one person i love was
like uh you know the robin williams is
and then and then you know the dana
carvies all that all those fools playing
characters on tv and then they they
would let me watch you know eddie murphy
richard pryor george carlin even me
he'll cover your ears on the back parts
you know and i'll be like that you know
and take it in
and then i remember it was the
early 2000s is when you know i had moved
up to san francisco and i was living
with a cousin i was going to school like
to try to you know do something good my
mom and dad were always that was
important so you moved to san francisco
to try to do what i was going to school
okay yeah and uh and my mom and dad were
just that what they that's all they
wanted all we want and i had a lot of
distractions down here so i was like you
know what let me get away and do this
and concentrate on that but i had family
up there
and so
and then that's when i started thinking
like damn i want to do the stand i'm
doing stand up and then i think it was a
good studio 2004 2005 when you dropped
why you crying yeah and homie i don't
mean i don't want to get all the eggs
but dude that that changed my whole view
on what we were like able to do because
i remember i was in this small apartment
in san francisco and i was watching i
got the dvd and i was excited and i took
the bus home and i put it put it on
and just every bit to the point where i
was jumping up and down watching it for
the third time when the neighbor
underneath was like knocking like hey
shut up and i'm like you don't
understand this is changing
right now you know
and uh and i started doing comedy later
that year you know and so it was just
like yeah so that was where did you go
to the first like cobbs
uh well i was going to laundry mats and
cafes doing my little opening
yeah yeah and so uh
you know there was a there was a place
called the brainwash cafe just recently
closed but it was the longest running
open mic up there in san pancho and then
uh you know and robin williams and all
these fools would drop in and people
would do their laundry so you had an
audience because they're waiting for
their laundry and they'd sit there and
watch you you know um
uh there's a lot of you know the dodgers
and the giants there's a rivalry in
comedy maybe not as much as it used to
be but if you were from san francisco
you kind of looked down on people that
were from los angeles because they were
they were there was the city rob
williamson up there really amazing
comedians up there well duress all those
guys so so it was hard to get
accepted by san francisco medians
because if you were from los angeles but
then
like that do a lot of laundromat coffee
shops like they found more places to do
it out there than we did it here like
they used to do comedy day in the park
those were those were amazing those are
great and and peaceful out there in
golden gate park and it set up the stage
and every club would have a list of
comedians that would represent the club
and it was fun to do that it's fun to
see
the whole a whole city supports stand-up
comedy you know they had the stand-up
comedy uh competition but
explain
to someone who
um
would probably never do stand-up in a
laundromat what
was
how
[Music]
they tell people what time it's going to
be
yeah yeah it was it was like you know it
was every thursday was the big one they
they started doing other nights but it
was thursday nights you know you sign up
at like 6 p.m yeah but i was working a
warehouse job doing the shipping and
receiving so i would get off and race as
fast as i could but you sign up your
name and i'd be late by that time so by
the time i got on it would be like you
know six people there but something i
mean i was just doing i just stuck with
it was doing it and uh uh yeah yeah it
was it was like when you went up there
and there were six people uh and and if
uh
if you if you if you did good i think
you're like happy but if you didn't do
well because of six people did it bother
you or did you say no that's just the
way it goes oh yeah i was like nervous i
had to get drunk just to get up there
i'm at a laundry mat or drunk like no
you could do this you know and then i'll
go up there and you know i did a lot of
sex and diarrhea jokes when i started
you know
but i got some laughs i was like all
right we got a little something but and
they had a little stage right there too
like a little like on somebody's basket
or whatever but they didn't have a say
to her you stand in a corner but
eventually they put a little like a
little i mean that's platform thing i
mean it's crazy you think about it like
stand up comedy in a laundromat
i mean yeah yeah you concentrate on the
comedian you're [ __ ] shorts i mean
what if he's up there and you're and it
stops the dryer do you go hey i gotta
put another quarter yeah
put another quarter in a dryer number
six for me all right the little boxes of
soap that you have to put in
pull them out uh um
and then um
did you have did you have guys that you
that you worked with up there or did you
kind of buy yeah you know you started i
started meeting people and then and then
working with them and then and then i
started getting a little get you know
you get that first
gig that pay me twenty dollars and two
free drinks and i'm like oh it's
happening
and then you know then obviously you
learned the aids and how did the creeper
character how did you find him uh it was
just based on my dad my dad was always
repping his you know he was a good
father always still had his chuck
taylor's dickies always had a low rider
my nino his best friend was president of
ito's car clever like 30 years so i was
always in that environment but my dad
was always there present and just like
hey meanwhile treat people with respect
show gratitude and handle your business
all right you know like always giving me
positive messages but you know wrapping
this thing with this pom-pom
and so yeah so i was like creepers an
extension of that you know my dad wasn't
into fitness but you know that's where i
tapped into like hey he wants to do
something good in there and and uh
explain uh uh uh the last floor is three
flowers to people there
yeah yeah it's a it's a you know pomade
it's a brand og brand you know og but
it's stage homie i mean it's gonna it's
gonna take you it would probably take
you if you start using thresh flores
right you know it'll probably take you
about you know a week to wash it out
like you know everywhere okay
it activates yeah yeah if my dad got was
stressed because at kmart that he got it
at he just thought it was available at
kmart and it closed down the kmart you
know the a lot of kmarts goes down and
he was stressed and stressed and my mom
found it on amazon got him a whole box
and he was like what uh-huh like all
right so so so in like in in chicano
households or in latino households if
you started to smell three flowers you
knew somebody was going out
so the what the woman would say or they
would say hey i don't know where the
[ __ ] you think you're going because they
smell the the
you're not going anywhere like what you
know they come out
and then it it it came out in the gl in
glass because everything came out in
glass until they found out it was bad
for the environment uh and then now it's
in a plastic
like a little vaseline thing yeah yeah
it lost its charm they had threshold
floaters and that was for that was more
expensive because the cheap stuff was
just palm eight yeah you know i i used
to use palm eight
and butch wax you know that
was floating that's a dick or something
wow root yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah uh so yeah the guys would uh
they were cert those were all the smells
of of chicago neighborhood
whatever they would do
stop that
[ __ ] tight
like [ __ ] tired yeah
um
and then the the for christmas you know
when when your family
uh
would think about you but then you
realize you know they would have the
english leather gift sets
where there would be three english
leathers with wooden knobs
and you would open it up and bring wood
and then i saw an english leather larger
thing with a with a larger wooden knob
and this chicano dude in san fernando
put the knob as his gear shift on in his
car
like screwed it on and glued it off
it was english leather
right there and he had the you know or
the little pata gas pedal all those
things that uh the the guys in my
neighborhood didn't use the english
everyone was using jd's
yeah jade east was the one uh
oh jd's that's right jd's was the one
that smelled good and all the girls
liked it so
yeah we didn't use that english letter i
would say in times like right now
uh what's important or used to be
important
was having a full tank of gas and the
way that gas is
uh and you're balancing your budget
getting some money from dave and being
able to run a full tank is the
difference between feeling comfortable
while you're on the road and going to
and from work as opposed to oh man you
know feeling that stress they're trying
to relieve the stress in your life dave
is the banking app that can help you get
up to five hundred dollars instantly
with extra cash there's more money to
fill your tank buy a wedding gift or
catch up on bills
you can finally tackle those expenses
that have been stressing you out without
any hangups
there's no interest and no credit check
needed
millions of people have already
downloaded the dave app to get financial
relief they need with extra cash so if
you're in a pinch and need some extra
help download dave and think of it as a
helping hand from future you download
the dave app from the app store right
now that was incredible
that's
d-a-v-e sign up for extra cash account
and get up to 500 instantly for terms
and conditions go to dave.com legal
instant transfer fees apply
banking provided by evolve member fdic
and the future you
will thank you
when you decided to do characters how
how did you do how did you how did you
break them in like how did you bring
them out
yeah did you go out as one or you would
be you have dudes walk out there there's
become one or yeah no well i was i'm
kind of i would be like a storyteller in
my stand up so i'll go into voices and
so natural i was like this epic kind of
naturally or i was like you know what i
should start committing more doing the
first one was like juanita carmelita so
i went up there like hey what's up you
know like doing that yeah
so she was the first one and i was like
whatever you know i was inspired because
i loved watching like all the character
work and even martin lawrence when he
did shania
you know that so i was like man i want
that you know and you know uh obviously
robin williams with all his characters
and and so uh you know when he did mrs
doubtfire i remember thinking like damn
he just you could you i couldn't believe
it was him he was so good
and so i was inspired by that yeah and i
started doing her and then i started
doing you know creeper when when cholofa
went viral i was like oh man i need to
come up with a stage act for him because
people wanted to see that you know and i
was just like so yeah yeah he just and
how did cholo fit because that's that's
where i think
everybody was sending that around you
know they were talking to each other and
they would say have you seen this dude
you know i got all kinds of people
telling me like hey you know this guy
you know feel the burn and
a lot of like millions right millions of
views man yeah yeah and
what was the process of doing the first
one of cholo fit like
did you wrote it out and you yeah we
wrote well we we wrote on one called
trolo whisper right which was like so
creeper got out of the crs the total
rescue services and his family rescued
him you know bobby lucy but they were
having problems with them because about
those while and they're like you know
hey we got to call troll whisper so the
homie comes in is my homie during
riverside and he has long hair and he
came with a cane and he helps them and
then so everybody's like you need to
make another one that one got like half
a million views and uh
uh you know bob eastside
like into it and he posted it on the
page i was like oh man and this was
years ago ten years ago
and so we redid the troll lowest price
and we're like well everybody said do
another one i said what's the next day
but he's got to get a job and so in the
in solo whisperer he was already kind of
doing some yard workouts and i was like
oh i know he could teach a workout class
in the backyard and we did that and most
of it was improv man and my dad was just
dropping off some tamales at the time
he's the og that we did the
trollometrics with the chest to chest
yeah and then we're like we i thought it
was funny but you know we posted it i
went to sleep that night i woke up in
the morning and it was like that it was
like my inboxes oh i'm getting messages
from australia and these two bottles in
australia they're doing a troll squad
they have a baby joey a baby kangaroo
between them like making it look like
he's doing a squat and they're like hey
charlo fit my you know they don't even
know what a trollo is but they they they
were attracted to the character for
whatever reason
and then so and then it just like yeah
it just it just went from there and then
so
yeah yeah and then we did the trollof it
advanced and then kept going and then i
just kept developing creeper and i
started studying because a lot of
people that in europe that don't even
speak english it was his physical
movements right i started studying
buster keaton benny hill
mr bean
uh all these fools that do the the old
school physics three stooges have you
seen mr bean yeah yeah dude he's in
benny hill yeah amazing amazing man
sometimes just their movements and so i
started trying to get a whole you know
tap into that side of creepers uh you
know
and then it's just like is he just
walking everything and you know
yeah yeah it's amazing the amount of
work you put in there to get it you know
people don't think about that i never
thought about that you know the studying
what you had to do to get prepared for
it
it's all and it all pays off it's it's
awesome it's
it's uh unbelievable and i can see it
right now i can go home and see it again
laugh my ass off i i just it's good
thank you good morning
the uh uh the uh
and uh but that you know but doing that
like on on
on video and instagram and social media
mm-hmm
it's not doing it in the clubs you know
exactly yeah so they're all very
different right so so you know you have
to build
maybe uh you know solid half hour or an
hour to be in the clubs but you could
have five videos that probably equal
maybe 10 minutes and you can't do that
in front of people but um yeah but how
did you do how did you find the balance
of like doing uh uh total fit things and
then doing stand-up because if if they
went to see you do stand-up they wanted
to see
you do creeper a little bit of trouble
fit up yeah yeah i would say yeah and
that was the thing i started doing
stand-up at the end of uh
2005 you know around there so a lot of
people thought i was just this youtuber
that oh he made this video and not
realizing that i had already been doing
stand-up for like i think already over
10 years at the time yeah and so to
so i was like kind of happy about that
because we've all seen youtubers fill
comedy clubs and sell tickets and no
knock on their hustle i'll never knock
anybody's hustle but they don't really
have a life they run out again it
becomes like a q a have you ever seen
one you said that you said that a few
times yes there was a club uh i don't
want to say the name zany's in nashville
[Laughter]
that was bringing in uh youtubers
because uh the manager of god what's his
name andrew
that
because they were because he felt like
they were so
hot at the moment that you could put
four together and maybe get them to do a
show but i think he understood that that
people would come out
but they would quickly run out of uh you
know run out of momentum let's say i
don't want to you know say momentum and
they would lose the ground yeah and then
at that time it's like you know
stand-up crowds listen man you never
know who's going to end up in there
sometimes they're nice sometimes they're
great yeah right you could do a hundred
shows that are great and then one where
they all [ __ ] turn on you and it's
quiet even when it's quiet and they
don't want to give you anything and they
could but they're all gonna go quiet
that's what that's what they would do to
them
right because they didn't know how to
pull a crowd out of
them stalling you out because they'll
stall you out and they'll see if you
could
pull yourself out of the stall like a
like a like an airplane pilot do you
know how to pull yourself out or are you
going to go down and you know how i know
how
i've gone to shows like where they
they're doing that they're they're don't
[ __ ] leave you hanging
i laugh because they're dying yeah i'm
laughing because they're dying everybody
else is stalling them out and i think
it's hilarious
you know you think you they don't think
you're funny i think it's funny that
you're dying
that's right and you'll get a laugh
you'll but it's not gonna be the laugh
that you want yeah at the lab factory
there was a guy that was doing like
airplane jokes and and [ __ ] [ __ ] like
that and i went up after and i said i
think we need to find a black box on his
act
[Laughter]
they all went [ __ ] crazy yeah that
was it moved on
i mean you know yeah yeah my little
thought though that was twecko went up
there one time and i walked up there and
i go man i feel bad i'm in this parking
place
i would find the ones to come on
you got to pull them out man
hey listen i always say what mike tyson
said
the reason mike tyson
when the bell rang ran at his opponent
because he wanted that guy to know that
he was in a fight as soon as possible
no [ __ ] where they touch gloves when
the bell would ring he'd go and get on
the dude and that philosophy i think
for me worked for me like let them know
that you mean business as quick as you
can
because if one minute goes by two
minutes goes by
three minutes goes by now they're
starting to look at each other and
they're going like
should we be worried about this dude or
what yeah then and then five minutes go
by and then the momentum shifts it's
like wrestling you have to end up on top
you might start on the bottom but you
try to hold them and then at the end end
up on top right it's completely
different yeah yeah
when you uh congratulations on doing the
wheel turn too oh thank you because i
know that was that's a that's a big that
was a big deal for you yeah yeah i think
i caught
let you know about it and i was just
like you know you gave me your blessing
i was like yeah that was awesome because
i would be
i worked at a lot of restaurants on
wheel tracks i was busting tables doing
whatever i could and i remember always
looking across the street they're like
because it's a different color you've
been to the wilton no it's an old like
art deco style theater and it's been
there for for a long long time historic
landmark historic yeah a lot of rock can
you see what you're the a lot of rock
bands a lot of comedians all comedians
uh
and to do it is very prestigious it's
like a it's like a uh it's like a big
deal to be able to headline uh the
wilton so he was doing he was doing that
chicago was out there during the day
taking pictures in the crosswalk
take a [ __ ] nap
you know what i thought take a [ __ ]
nap [ __ ] you got a show tonight
hold up traffic
you know
because
you know what the stamina was like they
want to take some fleet cause of y'all
say hey all right
one time i saw a female comedian
i'm not gonna say her name because she's
high up
and
we were all there's a there's an
unwritten kind of i don't know if it's a
rule or not but by three o'clock every
comedian who values
their time on stage pretty much would
try to be down in a sleep or whatever
from three to six would be
would be your down time we saw this this
this girl in aspen at the asp at the
aspen comedy festival and when we were
walking back to the hotel
before like 2 45 she was out there with
her friends drinking and we're like okay
like yeah yeah i don't know about that
and that night
you know yeah yeah not good no i got you
know how it is you gotta find when i'm
on the road and like hey i'm telling all
the other guys we gotta go eat right now
because i need to back right back in the
room by three that's why i take my nap
because you have to have a routine uh
uh to perform so that way you're not
because you know they're very
superstitious man if you
don't take a nap and then you bomb
you'll be like okay well i'm never going
to do that again and then you have to
get into
a pre-show routine
like golfers have a pre-shot routine so
they go
and do the same thing to hit the ball if
somebody talks you ever seen golf they
back
they back up and they do it all over
again so in their head they're trying to
mimic the same movement on every swing
so it becomes
almost robotic in the sport that you
can't be robotic
so with us
if you're traveling and the
car breaks down or it's snowing or
whatever all that should be in your head
is
i gotta [ __ ] rest because we gotta go
do this
not like you know i didn't get a chance
to sleep i hope i do all right like you
always find
the time to do that
um
in um
in traveling around the country where
have where have you gone have you been
have you done it in new york yeah
yeah where have you performed in new
york gotham comedy club yep in manhattan
yeah that one but you know i've done you
know they have a bunch of rooms
you know i'm still at that level where
i'm like well no but that's a big deal
you would go you would go and get times
in there and go in there and do do did
they know you were coming or you'd be
guessed no no they knew i was coming
yeah yeah and so it was cool yeah yeah
it was a you know actually a couple
times when i was at gotham uh uh
seinfeld dropped in you know and then he
did you know he's just working out his
stuff or whatever but it was just kind
of cool to be like
once be around like
why are they doing
why is that uh the uh
because it's almost like if you went to
a safari and you saw a lion
you know when you see seinfeld one of
one of the guys like one of the like i
remember when i was in 1980 i was
already doing it um and
we heard a big cheer in the comedy store
and there's a you know that doorway into
the main room and everybody ran to the
doorway and they opened up the door
opens this way and
[ __ ] robin williams was out there in
the clothes from mork and mindy oh [ __ ]
the khaki pants yeah the the jersey
and the rainbow suspenders
and i mean it was [ __ ] loud in there
man damn and he had and then later on
when i got to know him i told him that i
saw him there and he said that
oh yes he would always he would always
go and try to perform but he wouldn't
even wait to get out of his clothes like
he'd say oh i'll bring him back tomorrow
he would just go
as [ __ ] mork
[ __ ] more
you know
so and uh
it's a trip when you when you see
guys like that right i mean you've
probably seen some
the pretty [ __ ] big dudes out there
like and they treat it the same way
right everybody treats it with yeah with
respect yeah yeah it's a
good great learning experience and
eye-opening you know because you know
i've seen i met rob williams a handful
of times up in san francisco and i would
see him go on stage and he's trying to
work something out and just to see them
like damn even at your level homie we
still got to do do you think robin
whatever stole creeper he's walking
because he was a little bit uh
let me tell you a robin williams story
yeah yeah i know i know i probably know
what you're getting around
so
andre agassi has a foundation in las
vegas
and uh glen frye god rest his soul and
robin williams god rest his soul
uh we were me robin williams and glenn
frye were standing there and and glenn
frye says do you know why
the scottish work no underwear under
their kilts
and like uh we're like no he goes to
sneak up on the sheep
[Laughter]
[Music]
so robin williams is on stage and about
three quarters in he goes you know why
the scottish were kilts
to sneak up on the sheep and glen fry
looked at me and said
hey man
that's that's what it is hey and he had
just and he had just told him you know a
few hours earlier but i think robin was
just
on another you know kinetically maybe he
would probably be the only one that
could get away with it
a lot of other ones that don't get away
with that so i'm still laughing because
you mentioned two two stand up guys and
god bless her
yeah but i didn't hear you say god rest
her soul for olivia
now we just dumped on her
real quick
i'm gonna be in there
no hey listen i mean it's different i'm
a comedian
no that's all right that's a female
those are actors that's different um
but and and
uh
how much do you do how much do you do
now like
where do you where do you go um where
can people see what we're not but where
can people see you and all your websites
and all that oh yeah you know the social
medias and all that like i it's funny i
was like you know i'm 42 i'm going to be
42. but you haven't done parties have
you done parties as creeper like cholo
parties
no i haven't or would you would you do a
vip party i've gone to one where they do
that scamming jam downtown yeah they
play all the old school things that's
creeper what time is it
you know i'm just out there doing it
how do you think he would do if he was a
dj like he would go up there
and he was i already got
he'd be awesome whatever he did
yeah i'm serious i think he'd be awesome
or whatever he did like what
like dj stand up acting in front of the
going to private parties he is his
personality's outgoing he's vivacious
would you ever thought you were thinking
about being a dj i think you're
vibrations
yeah no i've thought about that like hey
[ __ ] dj's man they oh yeah they like
creeper sunday kickback or something
like i would want to do a daytime brunch
thing i just played all these old
schools listen man if you if you did a
party
at a at a pool during the day
out of somewhere in l.a yeah and jammed
oh man we could do some troll aquatics
in the pools
hey you know how much those dudes make
man dj's six figures man plus oh yeah
they make
make a lot of money it's crazy yeah i
got some dj homies everybody hey cholo
jam there it is okay so uh victor dre
you know dre's out there in las vegas
victor dre has a big uh
pool party during the day
over there in las vegas dress yeah yeah
dress yeah yeah
legendary you talk to uh
you talk to your publicist
and
you let me know
if you want to do dress
on the labor day weekend saturday that
you'll be there and that i'll be in town
oh what and i'll co-host it with you
during the day and let's see if it flies
let's see if
let's see let's see if there's a way
because do it brother dude
those dudes make bank man i'm telling
you man my birthday's uh the the fifth
is september 5th is that that i think it
might be that weekend that's amazing
they make way more money
i mean
what what does this name steve aoki
and uh yeah
and let's see man because that would be
awesome you know i'm not a big deal dude
he's going to be there and and i just
before i ever hooked up with him i'd
seen him a bunch that i'd pay to go see
him
and so now i just like seeing him and i
thought let's just get away for the
weekend let's go to vegas but i was
nicer before he knew me i mean he thinks
i'm mean to him
as soon as somebody likes me i start
getting mean
hey don't get too close okay so bring
that dog over here
so we're going we're going to go up
there we're going to be up there that
that weekend so
that would be double that'd be doubly
bad weekend for me i think you know you
know why because because
listen not because of anything other
than
it's so unique and it's and he's so
lovable
that why not have an alternate stream of
of income
just having fun yeah
yeah i'm sorry i wore my speedos
i mean russell pete russell peters
russell p yeah come on the roblox peels
russell russell peters dj's
he's real into it yeah he's a good dj
and he uses the money from djing as
child support only okay
oh
put all that stuff back
um but yeah i mean um
you have a show and you have a show too
right are you develop the show that you
explain to me the show that you have on
is it hulu yeah hulu comes out this
friday actually yeah that's right yeah
well this will air whenever
what day does it come out that this is
the 12th
is this friday the 12th no yeah that's
this friday oh
i'll put it up on instagram and facebook
that
this clip like this so what what what
concept is it was it yours or you got
cast in it it's my it's my home it's my
homie uh chris estrada you know he's
from south central he's loosely based
off his life actually but he was opening
for me for the for about three and a
half years we toured together and i knew
him a long time and then the producers
i've known for like 10 years
uh but then you know like fred harmerson
and jonathan groff stepped on it and
it's just like
you know it's like a uh
uh you know luis i play luis i'm just
out of the i spent eight years in prison
i get out my cousin julio's trying to
help me get into this place called hugs
not thugs which is kind of like another
kind of homeboy industries kind of place
you know but i'm like emotionally
immature you know i'm like you know just
always clowning on them you're like you
don't know me
but but you know i ain't [ __ ] he ain't
[ __ ] really because we both live
on my tias which is his mom
and he tries to talk to me like hey i'm
going to get you in this program i'm
going to help you get your life together
and i'm like come on fool you ain't [ __ ]
you know we're not sleeping you know
right here you know and it's like yeah
yeah it's very grounded it kind of
reminds me of like the movie friday
meets a show atlanta yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that's
good that's right yeah yeah i said
michael imperioli is a is in it he's one
of like our plays the the minister in
the place yeah that's awesome
that's
uh
christopher montesante yeah yeah uh
that's a big that's that's huge but if
he's in it that's big yeah and how many
episodes did you guys uh ten yeah yeah
they're dropping all ten there's more
than any of them
no no all right good because
if you want that [ __ ] shoulder last
don't put that button hey i love
is
it's a bird wrapped in bacon
uh uh yeah i mean i think that there's
um
clearly
um
paths that weren't there before you know
for latino shows uh i think that uh
um
congratulations on on your neutral homie
yeah
no
okay all right don't worry about that
one never mind oh no no but thank you
i'll put you on that one if you're
allowed to
are you allowed to to do other shows
with that yeah yeah
yeah i'm like yeah yeah
al's in it
yeah yeah yeah cause al you know i got
lucky the first time i had valente as my
as my best friend and let me let me tell
you how casting how casting is like for
people that don't know so so
we you know my my real friend was named
ernie and then i create the show and i
write we write that guy ernie and we
wrote him as like kind of a
uh
not good with girls kind of simple like
big brother little brother you know and
uh
there was not a lot of uh actors
to be able to play that guy like there
wasn't a lot there was this guy
uh luis i think he's now rob he's from
new york
which was not
a type you know from new york we're from
i was from san bernardino and valencia's
from from um
from texas so that guy was would be
as far away from the true character as
you could be but we needed to take two
to abc to the network into abc so it
kind of just took him along
and
valente had already been in blood and
blood out he was in erin brockovich like
he had he had done some act some acting
i hadn't done really any
and uh
uh around december 18th of 2001
we had finished writing the pilot and we
started to read actors and you know i
wasn't an actor
uh and the crazy part is
nobody asked me if i could act
somebody said hey can you act by the way
i would have said i don't know i think
we're gonna i'll find out together so
nobody nobody ever saw me act they saw
me write but they never saw me act
so
we brought valente in toward the end of
this and this is a this is this is a
tale for all people who want to be
actors
uh uh is to
not take your not imagine your own
talent would be enough to get you there
but to go get trained so
he was already a trained actor and they
said they said to me
why don't you guys read together so i
said all right and i was so bad
that both of my partners looked at each
other like
okay
we don't have to do
right so i saw i saw in their eyes that
they were like oh [ __ ]
this guy
so when i left and got in home i called
my manager i said hey man you got to
find me an acting coach
you got to find me a coach like today
and i used it all during the holidays
went back read better then we started at
the end of february 2002 and that lady
stayed with me
all 120 episodes and i saw her after and
now mine goes to a coach that's at her
studio but
i didn't take it for granted that i
would be enough to know
enough about acting to make that show
stick so
um i went and got i went and got trained
like i didn't take it for granted so
when when
we took the guys to abc he took luis and
you took valente
the first guy went in there and he
they said are you ready and he had i
don't know if he had the sights
but he just went forward and did it
right so
when valente walked in
under his breath i heard him say oh [ __ ]
because it's a it's a it's a dark room
and there's a stage over there and
that's the only part that's lit and all
the important people are kind of in the
five rows up and sandra bullock was in
there and everybody's not all of us were
in there and he couldn't really see us
and then the person that's reading with
you is in there and he came in there
and he just said hello and you know we
said hey thanks for coming and then he
turned his back
to the to us
right had his back turned
and the casting person said are you
ready and he said yeah
and the other member the other dude went
straight ahead right
and he said
he said yeah and when he turned around
he had that simple
look on his face that that dude ernie
had kind of like a you know with his
[ __ ] ears hanging out
and he didn't make a sound and everybody
started laughing
just without even talking and then he
did the scenes and it worked and when he
walked by i said hey puto i think he
just got hired
uh and i think that got him the job was
turning his not only being prepared but
he turned his back
to give them something to start with not
like the other guy just went yeah i'm
ready and he you never saw him change
types
right right and he had his back turned
and when he turned around he was the
character
not the guy who walked in and that
said a lot and nobody nobody no but i've
never seen any you know we hired a lot
of actors
since then i've never seen anybody do
that never seen anybody turn around
to start
acting wow yeah yeah yeah i did that in
a one audition but it was i was doing
characters though you know you turned
around right yeah he was he was too so
yeah
but yeah yeah did you try to get into
like groundlings or second city or i
didn't do none of that man i was just
using i was kind of just doing my own
content
i mean not that i knocked that i
probably probably would have done it the
opportunity came but i was i loved doing
stand-up you know right so that's what i
was mostly dedicated to and then yeah
and then what do you like better stand
up or are you like
characters and there are other other
characters that you that you bring out
yeah i got imo primo who's like you know
it was that classic he has his hair like
that like everything's so lame you know
yeah but like um
and then you know and then that jc and
creeper and then you know i've been
working developing some other ones too
but uh
but oh i got rudy rodriguez you know
he's a guy you know old rocker dude you
know a place plays the local casinos and
stuff like that that's me yeah
that's why
but yeah it was fun to get in the car
even this character for for this full
they they knew i wasn't handed that role
you know right like you said they were
picturing a bigger buffer like ivato and
then and then they kind of they were
like you know what they they wanted me
to like kind of help with the role i
kind of maybe punch it over just start
reading for they knew that i was going
to be part of the show even just in the
writers room or something i don't know i
don't know what capacity
but then i started reading for the raw
and then it was like jonathan grafford
did blackish and all that he was like
hey you know what he brings a more
interesting vibe to it like a joe pesci
vibe right and like it makes it more
interesting so we reinvented the
character and i was like yeah you know
i'm there talking and i'm like yeah yeah
you know whatever you guys need but in
my head i'm like come on let's just get
right
is it 10 episodes and might get picked
up for more or how do you know
if uh
do the 10 episodes have a have an arc to
them or
yeah yeah they do yeah so yeah you know
uh so yeah yeah we're just uh you know
comes out this this friday it's looking
good you know i don't know we'll see
what happens but you know for us to get
a second season but you know you know
what what i think is i don't i don't
really watch a lot of comedians uh now i
don't uh you know i
i really never have really kind of
watched any communities i don't really
kind of go to the clubs anymore but um
uh but the things that you see
uh growing up
i think that
become parts of your act even with
things that you don't know who's going
to
be who or
you know who's going to do what so there
was like there was a couple that lived
next door to my friend guillermo and and
the guy was a truck driver so you know
yeah he had the
kind of beer belly but tucked in shirt
on the belt and and and cowboy boots and
he was a drunk driver
and his wife was named mickey
uh little scrawny you know lady
and perez [ __ ] mickey right so mickey
the dude was a
truck driver long range so you long
range so you could
also you know if you had somebody out
like she had dudes going in and out of
that house and we were like on our bikes
we were like that's five
so
we hear this truck coming down the
street it's the dude but he's not he's
home
like he would come on saturday or sunday
this was like a tuesday
so we were always playing in the street
he was never there tuesday because you
know what cars go by the same car in the
same neighborhood and he's like
and the things flap and smoke comes out
and we're looking at the car go by
and
the window
on the side of the house kicked open
and a dude jumped out
naked with the shoes like you see in the
movies that's how you see the movies
ran to the backyard got ran down the
alley
he kind of went like that like what the
[ __ ] did he goes in there
mickey she ran through the screen door
you know where the screen door locks
sometimes
and you don't have time to if you're
trying to grab it you know sometimes it
closes and it locks
she ran through the screen door and left
like a cartoon where it would be like
that she left the silhouette like wiley
county but when she ran through and the
[ __ ] dude is he and then he ran
through he didn't even try to open the
screen door
and then he ran through but he's holding
a [ __ ] guitar and running with an
acoustic guitar
so she's running to the street
and she's she's saying no no no and you
know we're on our bikes man we're right
there do you look yeah
you know and she's running around us on
the bikes and she's saying like help me
look at 12.
how were you she didn't have a bra
with a song
so she's right around the street the
dude's chasing and then he did one of
these
yeah they did like and he caught her and
and did the [ __ ] el cabon under him
he hit her over the head
with the acoustic guitar oh
and broke the guitar bro
they hit her with the back part of it
and then the strings went this way but
her head was sticking out of the guitar
and the neck
was out [ __ ] sideways and she's
sitting in the street like this with a
guitar
around her neck
and she said
you don't love me anymore do you
the whole neighborhood was outside we're
all laughing at the same time
and she tried to and her kids were
trying to get the acoustic guitar around
her neck but the strings they were still
off the strings didn't break so it was
like yeah it was like being caught
between the fence and the pole
but i mean
how long before she moved out
oh they moved that it was sad when they
moved on it because you know all that
all kinds of different [ __ ] happened at
that house
oh my god oh my god crazy huh
that's insane
if i didn't carry looney tunes by the
character have you chased me with a
guitar and hit me over the head
[Music]
uh how big an influence was was cheech
to you
oh man big time because because if you
look at chi-chi look at let's look at
creeper
and let's look at creeper creepers from
where
from east ely yeah just from you know
from there
so so cheech created this character
which is like you know cheech was a what
do you do he do him and him and tommy
met in canada yeah uh or dodging yeah
i mean
yeah well it's okay
hey his old man was a lieutenant with
lapd when he retired yeah yeah no i
found that out recently when we i did a
show with him right at one time so
cheech's mother mrs marine got rest her
soul
worked at alemany high school
right by where you were born
on rinaldi in mission hills
and when we were at san francisco
or no 1979 we decided we were going to
have a battle of the bands
at the at the auditorium
and we wanted to
take flyers out to all the other schools
and we when we got some pretty wild
bands that performed
and we went to alemany
and it said on the wall of the plaque
you know my you know i talk about you
remembering everything i thought pretty
good says mrs it says mrs marin
and i look at that and i kind of knew
that i mean up in smoke had already
happened i think maybe
next movie was around there around that
time
and then
uh she turned around
and she was a little
uh mexican lady
with the glasses of the chain and she
looked like cheech but without a
mustache
like a little like a little anita you
know like a little randy
so i i said uh
i said are you
are you cheech's mom
and she said
yes richard is my son
oh and then i said
uh so you know him
and she goes yes
he's my son
i said you talk to him
uh and she goes yes you have his phone
number and everything
she's like yeah i gave birth to him
so you do know him yeah
i'm telling you
so
i had never been close to cheech at that
time i mean they were in 1978 but seeing
his mom
i didn't meet him until probably 10
years later like 88 and then i told him
that you know i told him that story and
he said
yeah my mom was like you know
anti-weed like you know my dad was a cop
anti-weed
so
we would look for places to stash our
weed because our mom would the mom would
all be looking for the weed so he's like
well you can't put it in the house so at
you know all those mexican the mexicans
backyards where
they could put three houses in the
backyard it's a little house but then
they got the [ __ ] lots like a triple
lot
so at the end of the yard they had a
beacon de guadalupe
statue
alter in the corner
of the furthest part and and when they
make them
you know they wanted to have that they
have the mold
they have like a hole underneath yeah
yeah yeah always in the middle right now
i was in the middle so he would go over
there and stash his weed in the vegan
the guadalupe statue
and then he goes but when i moved out i
forgot it no
but i didn't remember i forgot it he
goes and then
15 years later when my sisters were
older and they were looking to hide
their weed they went to the back
and tried to hide it in the statue and
they put their hands under and they
pulled his weed out
that was there for like 15 years and the
sister called him and goes hey how do we
find your weed
in the beat in the guadalupe statue
that'd been in there for like for like
15 years
because you know when you're maybe she
blessed it i don't know because he had a
good career
it's gotta
i mean the last thing you wanted to do
was be a marijuana in a mexican family
oh yeah yeah yeah
back then if you were late that'd be
like you might know where the [ __ ] where
the [ __ ] is he
i had a joke where they where the guy
said uh
when they started to do drug testing
where they would go hey gil got a new
job at
rite aid oh yeah do they know that he's
a marijuana you know not yet you go to
write a crack let's go attach it right
aid
gills about him
so in the in these 10 shows
what's can you give us a little bit of
the arc of the of the shows
uh yeah i mean you know yeah
yeah they're releasing all ten okay at
the same time
yeah yeah it's like i get you know
my my primo comes to pick me up the
first day and then you know we go to my
dias i kind of get you know getting back
in there you know and i'm thinking i'm
going to kick it my tea is like nah you
know what i want you need to get to work
and you know and so
you know he so julio convinced her well
he needs to join hugs not thugs then
because we need to get him in this
program so i'm very resistant you know
and he has me in there baking cupcakes
and i'm grabbing the
the apron says hug me on it i'm grabbing
them you know like putting it on you
know and i don't want no part of it at
first but eventually you know i take a
liking to it and then start homing up
with minister payne which is you know
michael imperioli
and then um you know and then
uh it's the julio you know chris
character he has a a lover relationship
a lady that he keeps breaking out
getting back together maggie he played
by michelle ortiz
and then you know and then we have the
tia and then we have the abuelita you
know and she only speaks spanish and
then uh who's that who's playing that uh
julia julia uh you know you know oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah she's she says oh gee
yeah
but yeah i didn't even know she's from
like she's like eight in her 80s and
she's just like so quick and everything
yeah yeah there's a lot i think real
women have curves i think uh they were
all going to have curves yeah so so
that one you got cast in are you are you
writing things for yourself like do you
are you trying to yeah yeah
actually yeah we're working on a
schedule with with the you know al and
and hcc and uh colton dunn who was a
writer on key and pill yeah uh we're
developing a schedule right now that we
hopefully would you could you see
yourself in a sitcom like creating a
sitcom or
i think right i think you have the
from what you said about your family i
think your grandfather and your parents
and stuff like that i see
i would say i would see a nucleus of a
show oh yeah yeah that'd be great man i
mean i mean your show obviously is
something my parents still watch these
days it's on repeat but it was like that
one was so easy to watch man it's so
relatable and it was just like across
the board like you know
anybody could relate to that that show
and so i wanted something like you know
just a you know multi-cam show i could
picture you know myself doing that but
i think
i think that's what uh
i would say man i think that's where the
folk i think i think if i were you
don't you think i mean that's really
where
i mean i mean sketch is great
but but
you know
uh i'm gonna say
like if like that like that
it's hard to get a show to last it's
hard to get any show to last sketch is
still kind of a bit of a of a unique
it's unique in its self it's not you
know they don't see a lot of schedules
there there are sketch shows comedy
central and stuff but not maybe not on
network it was like whose line is in any
ways i mean you have to idea has to be
completely different but but um
in in a sitcom in a sitcom let's say
the reward is is uh
last longer you would say right
um
you know
created by credit you know you you plan
roots down the show goes seasons and
like stuff like that and you start to
you know kevin james
you know you see ray romano
you see drew carey
roseanne
um that time i was in store in the
company so i was at the comedy store
roseanne was doing the johnny carson
show on a wednesday
and roseanne was doing her last set or
second to the last set before wednesday
at the comedy store in the in the
original room the the room on the side
yeah yeah so we were we were in the back
and the mc goes there's a lady coming
for she's from denver
and she's making her premiere on the
tonight show on wednesday and roseanne
goes up there
oh she does her tonight show set she
goes yeah i never go anywhere i never do
anything because i'm a domestic goddess
so about the first
maybe not even 30 seconds
it was a little bit quiet
and then probably she probably did like
maybe 10 minutes and [ __ ]
killed i mean killed him like [ __ ]
i'm incredible
and then i watched wednesday
killed on wednesday
and then you know got the show
and you can say her name to anybody
and everybody would know all about
so i mean if you go down that road i
think it's a good road for you because
because culturally we don't have a lot
of people like you
like there's a lot of actors but an
actor
could maybe create a show for himself
but it wouldn't have the depth that your
that your life has or
or creeper has or your grandfather had
or your grandpa or your parents have
you know what i'm saying no yeah so i
think in in a show that
you would want to have a legacy the
legacy would be
to be able to bring your past to life
and to leave it as something that you
did
that's something that could say hey i
watched
and kids would say i grew up and watch
your show man it's like your your show
is my childhood
you know and i think when you're unique
and
i mean
you know the to get followers and to get
views is it it's it's on a it's on the
surface
but in order to really last i think you
make your
you make your [ __ ] bed on on network
or something you try to write a you know
yeah yeah i i think it's a great idea
yours has lasted so long it was great
you said everything's it's relative you
know it is relative
uh your show the only thing i couldn't
get relative to you had a second story
the stairs coming down yeah
this i never had a place to play a
slingshot there were there were no
second story houses
mexican family you know what's crazy
about that you know when the the set the
the designer the guy that looks for the
sets and stuff yeah yeah he says uh i
still remember he came to me
show hadn't even aired
and he's like
you know i know you're from san fernando
give me a little bit of like a a square
of where you want me to look for a house
that would represent where you came from
so i said go to like uh
savannah road up to third street in san
fernando to the junior high and then to
mcclay
or or down to hubbard
the next week the guy comes has a video
cassette he goes can i show you things
showing me
and none of the houses are
to me look
look special or anyway
but growing up
that was the neighborhood that was we
considered the better neighborhood
so my eyes changed from
high school to seeing those houses where
we thought that rich people would live
or or people that were doing better than
other people
and then when i saw it as an adult
it wasn't anything
near what we would have liked to have to
have you know
and then we found that kind of uh
carpenter's house that two-story house
that
that they used uh i think i think uh
the buyer's remorse or whatever the
[ __ ] show no the upshaws use it the
upshots use my house as their house
but with my car not their car they're
just they really just kind of took the
picture
and show it coming in and out of
commercials that's that's the house that
we used on oh wow i didn't know that on
the show but then you know now people go
over there and they take pictures on the
show and all that stuff so
so uh
if you need help
i'll get you carlos mercier's phone
number oh yeah
the uh though
but but but you know i i i think you
should start and now and now too you
know like
in this show in the lopez versus lopez
show i i wanted l
i told l like three years ago man i said
hey i got this got this idea for the
show
you know i would love for you to be my
best friend and there we go we started
wednesday
congratulations that's why al hasn't
been calling so i would have
yeah
i'm not worried about you
the the uh but i think i think
i would like to see you do that i'm not
sure what you're working on
but i think that that would be
a good direction for you to go on
yeah um yeah and i'm willing to help you
do that girl you too cover them yes i'll
help you out
whatever george says
interesting lifestyle that's right i'll
be your deal yeah there you go hey yeah
you play good he seems like you play
good can you act or not well
if i put you on my show could you you
could you think you could get through it
i know i could get through it
hey i believe him yeah
the way
there's nothing there's but there's
really nothing like
that that lifestyle like you know that
eight to five or nine to five job then
yeah especially the multicam
there's not a lot of multi-cams
so you know i think the mistake i made
the first time but i was i wasn't i
wasn't all the way well was that
i didn't use the opportunity to
create other shows
because they always come to you and they
say
um
do you have any other ideas for shows
right right and this time it's different
i'm gonna say
yeah i got an idea of a guy who was
uh a police officer went to vietnam
his son makes [ __ ] socks and sells him
on the internet
don't lab he does hey
for real oh for real
is that unique like the dude's
eunuch he's always behind he's always
behind so he's talking to you while he's
sewing hey rosie grier could do that
[ __ ]
look at my son
wait wait so you you use it to keep your
yeah well i i don't think i don't use
them are they for dancers or are they
just a regular guy oh yeah look for
anybody there house of betch on
instagram house of batch bash yeah
who's that dude and that's just one i
know i went to one that really showed up
let's see that's some dude that's tired
hey here's another one
oh come on got a real low angle wow
congratulations what what are they what
are they used for just decorations like
i think they're used for you know the
date night or something these guys that
uh
in in the community in the gay community
these guys dress up you know i i guess i
don't know i don't [ __ ] use them but
he he makes them with
he's had shows you know where they walk
the runway for their mexican designs usa
designs
uh
you could do anything dogs mickey mouse
anything you want so they look warm
they're like
yeah they got a lot of theirs
they're primarily i i think they're for
show you know i don't know that they're
are they for no are they for like a big
night out or or i don't know i've never
used them because i don't know i don't
want to get into his business you know
i think the three of us should put them
off and [ __ ] do a poster
i'm trying to see if i can find more
info on it like it's you know but i mean
um
i think we should do that i think we
should start to develop
oh man i would be honored
right don't you think i'd
yeah i think i have i'm always writing
like something obviously most of it you
rip up and throw away like ah man i
thought this was funny but
i wrote a uh you know whatever don't
ever throw them away i've been working
on this feature script for controller
fit the rise and fall creeper you know i
want it to be a little bit kind of naked
gun slapstick but this and that but
there's like this community center and i
always had you and there was like the og
in the neighborhood that emilio i
mentioned it to emilio vera but i was
like
i always had you in there it's like
you're running this community center and
you're like man you needed to fill these
classes and then so
do an impression of immediate acting
are you doing that
what does he do
don't be bringing your [ __ ] over here
with them nobody wants to [ __ ] see
that eh
don't be bringing your [ __ ] toys over
here nobody wants to succeed
hey i love you we love you
no but but uh um
and my other advice to you are you ready
for it
um i think there needs to be
some of you agree
i think there needs to be some isolation
if you plan to
have a career that's
long i would say you know i
i always
remove myself from other comedians
because
early on like my friend ernie would say
you know
in the beginning i needed somebody to go
with me like you know i was like i'm one
i couldn't i didn't no you know we never
want to go anywhere by ourselves
so
he would say hey let's go at 7 30 and
then he started to flake on me which you
always did but around 7 15 and a lot of
times i didn't go
and then i started to think when you
know it happens for like the 10th time
it's like hey man and i didn't want to
go by myself because it's scary to go by
yourself yeah and you know you got to go
and park and try to get in you don't
have your you know anybody to talk to or
anybody like that and i mean i started
to go by myself because i thought to
myself well if i'm going to try to do
something in this business you're not
going to be able to do it
when you have to rely on somebody to go
with you because you can't go by
yourself right and i think that in our
community we get to the point where if
it's a ride or if it's support or if
it's whatever
you always want somebody to be with you
as a bit of a of a security
blanket or it'll be able to make you say
good luck you know but
i think it's detrimental i would say to
the longevity of somebody because now
you don't know
those guys work ethic maybe you do but i
think that you know they have that
saying if you want to go
fast
go with somebody and if you want to go
far go alone
and
and i and i would say to you
as you start because this is a show this
is another
step okay now will you after this show
will you take
another step up or you take a another
step up will you write that movie will
you will you do that movie will you sell
your own show or
if you surround yourself with people i
mean it just doesn't feel like
you're you can stall out but you can man
because i got a lot of respect for you i
wouldn't be telling you this if i didn't
think that
that that i thought that you were
special
that sometimes when you have people
around you man you can't do your work
because you're trying to do work as a
group like there can be time for that
but there also has to be time for
your drive and and what you want to
accomplish yeah
right that do you think that's
i mean that's true oh yeah yeah i
definitely think that's true that makes
sense i mean you know i mean you know
you this thing will
put you in some weird places sometimes
you know it's not everything you dream
of i'm like damn it'd be cool if i could
get on tv when it'd be good if i got a
special good got my own show and then it
starts to happen is never what you
imagine it to be because all of a sudden
you're like these deadlines and things
and they're stressing but you're
grateful at the same time but that you
could easily get caught up in too much
going on and things going around and you
forget to hey homie you got to
concentrate on your voice and getting it
out there it's like you said creating
that longevity and also you have to
create a bit of a
of a uh
a barrier so that if somebody hasn't if
somebody's having a crisis
it's not your crisis like if you're if
somebody's going to come and see you
wednesday from let's say hbo or whatever
and
your friend says oh man i [ __ ] got an
offender bed what do you mean man i
don't man i don't have a [ __ ] car
dude how are we going to get over you
know whatever whatever happens
when you're with your when you're on
your own you're more in control of what
can happen than
than relying on other people to be there
at a particular time i just think that
i've seen guys go and i think a lot of
guys get shows and then
not
have the show not go and then they go
back
to where they were but almost almost
like in a game you have to go two steps
back
and then because sometimes when you get
something like a show they look at you a
little bit different a little bit harder
on you because you got to think it's
like you know uh and and
you end up not being in this in the same
spot as
you might have been before
you know so for you
uh
i think you should i think you should do
a ruby tuesday dude have you done ruby
tuesday
yeah no no i haven't done ruby tuesday
for i know what show you're talking
about yeah but yeah yeah sure right i'd
love to
factory right yeah reuben paul's tuesday
show of the live action no every tuesday
yeah
[Music]
it's like a chain restaurant yeah what
are those two
how the [ __ ] use ruby that's like
xerox company yeah yeah uh i think you
should do one of those
yeah oh you mean like start my own no or
do it with me like a show oh yes call me
i would be honored yeah right do it you
know
yes oh yeah i've been there twice for
ruby tuesday with you
i think you should i want you i want you
to
i want you to see that
i want them to see you do that
all right yeah all right
hey you guys remember you said that
right i'll be there yeah
yo what is it uh
but you know hey man uh
i appreciate you for your talent dude
serious man i have a soft spot for you
because
uh i i think you're great and i really
do
man this is coming from you on me i know
it sounds cheesy but it's right here but
i mean i have respect for you man i i i
just want to see because we did that
thing for el chicano the the the cholo
fed thing we did with that lotus and
[ __ ] was oh yeah it was great man
we did this thing over here we were out
there in calgary you know ben was like
hey george is here you know and then i
was like
do you think you know i was like too
nervous to even go on your trailer then
i was like but i just walked around the
tree like i could feel energy all right
let's go
i think ben should release your
performance just for you could put it on
your reel did he ever give it to you for
your reel nah he said it was in the uh
there it is on the director's cut yeah
yeah so let's see if we can't find it
and put it on can we put it on we're
going to
try and find it yeah yeah ben the guy
that was here ben ben bray yeah yeah
yeah yeah
he's directing a lot of he's directing a
lot of shows yeah yeah
he's out there man and then with joe
carnahan yeah those guys are great yeah
all right let's let's do it man uh
remind everybody your handles and then
your show comes out yeah just uh at
frankie quinones uh and then um you know
trollo fit creeper i you know ig and tic
tac and
and then um yeah this full it premieres
uh august 12th or will be available now
on hulu all ten episodes
uh yeah if you have time local stand up
anything scheduled yeah i got well i got
a show at the california arts theater in
escondido on uh saturday august 27th and
then in september i'll be at denver
comedy works
miami improv and then the uh
uh las vegas uh live factory when you're
gonna be in miami
uh i think it's uh the end of september
why when are you going i'm going to be
there
in miami
this month i'm going to talk for three
days i'm going to do some lectures
investigation up there lecturing lecture
what's the name of your tour called
yeah it's just
i know i don't have a name for it
frankie does comedy hey it's me
hey [ __ ] i'm over here
uh
uh yeah all right and uh which comedy
works the one uh downtown yeah that's a
good one yeah yeah i've done the one
outside a little bit too but i like that
one
i like them both but i like the downtown
just that you know it's smaller but it's
still like
if we wrote material for you would you
do five minutes to stand up
yeah
although i i got to tell you i just
talked to this about the old with the
old lady uh i've been married 51 years
so i i talked to her in a row no no yeah
yeah
almost almost so the momo's been trying
to talk those guys been trying hey do 10
minutes we'll write for where i and you
you have fun up there they like
they love you though right the people
see you love you yeah and and and so i
told the wife i said what do you think
about me jumping up there tim and doing
stand up
and she said uh
no i don't think so
so
you say five minutes i'll do it
that's simple i wouldn't do ten
all night stalker
five minutes i do you write it i'll do
it
oh oh
you want me to get it how many i'm how
many i'm going to get an acting coach
not yet all right but i think you can do
it it's almost like an interrogation but
you need to talk louder yeah
right more people
have you ever performed at steven's
steakhouse oh yeah god damn yeah it's
been a long time yeah brother
yeah
inside the one in
oh yeah of course something hey when's
he doing another outside show saturday
i i don't check his schedule on
i i don't know when there's something
good he lets me know and i go down and
eat yeah and has the low the patio like
outside without awning over here now
he's getting now he's doing he put four
thousand people they block off the
street he's doing street shows out there
now
oh yeah no in that parking lot but they
built the whole stage for that right
yeah with the whole yeah yeah yeah
what did they have comedy dead comedy
night over there
they've had indoors you know i i just
put on comedy shows there for
fundraisers for homicide bureau and for
the national latino peace officers
associate put 400 people inside in the
in the uh
in their banquet room
and that's where i first met guys like
the guy you say is gonna do my life
story fluffy
uh
you know
him
dr
dr kim
oh yeah you know he was there uh
bowdoin
alonzo bowden yeah i love atlanta i love
obama he's badass he's good people i
love comedy and we put on shows there
and it was easy
now
he's ready to put on a big one okay
so
whatever whatever when this show air in
two weeks uh this airs on monday all
right um
all right
every week we're gonna touch in we're
gonna we're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna have your make your interest and
we're gonna start to create your set all
right
all right
all right
and i already got your first line
[Laughter]
all right should we start start on your
show
yeah all right
because i'm hot i thought i'm [ __ ]
right now hey let's do it you don't live
i don't i live close to you so all right
let's do that i'll be here all right
good grant awesome
thanks so much oh thank you welcome back
appreciate it good to be back yeah you
look good here
it's good to have you here
grace korean
and she checked us oh no no
but she cuts hair like that
don't cost me [ __ ] you know it's it's
it's it's not about the prices don't
cost you [ __ ] well i got you money yeah
no no i i it's it's like she she does
men's haircut 10 bucks
so she'll get 5 10 buck tip and that's
it i was you know a guy that i used for
years i was giving him 30 bucks plus a
tip that was years ago i grew up with
this guy yeah she and she's quit she's
good she's nice i love her
my grandkids go there now
the the the family what's the name of
the what's another the place
uh
[ __ ] i don't know i know only in order
yeah yeah don't give away did you uh
when did you shave your head
actually it was in the pandemic when
they should close all the barbershops
you know i was already i had the
helicopter pad going back i don't
remember do you remember him with hair
no well
i yeah i do i kind of don't remember you
having hair dude yeah well i i i had my
head shaved from that time i was like a
teenager like 26 but then i grew it out
but then i was already kind of getting
the helicopter pad back here but i would
get a tight fade to get the illusion
like he just has a tight fade he's not
losing it
but i needed that barber i needed to go
see him like every 10 days and they
closed during the pandemic so when
everything was shut down i said you know
what i'm just going to shave it and then
all of a sudden i got i started getting
a bunch of work right
so i said all right let me just keep it
like that there it looks good can i tell
you who it reminds me of before we go
you can do anything you want it's your
show
[ __ ] atc
right here
you see how much power i don't know the
[ __ ] code to open the door in front
hey you know what you know i talked
about chewie and andy today andy andy
vargas
he says they're like hey what's over and
he was like i just talked about yeah
what's going on with andy vargas he's
just over there in toronto he has a
couple days off you know they're going
to play i think uh
day after tomorrow
but uh chewie was like hey come up with
george for the part the party at the
park
there it is he's the resemblance the
golden child with eddie murphy
[Laughter]
oh that's right hey uh i'm going up
there the i'm going up to the 19th
yeah yeah that's so true it's for the
war the the thing at the park
um
i'm i'm getting i'm getting a plane so
uh
so i fit in there
see if your wife will let you go because
sometimes when you go on a private plane
they're like i don't know i mean
you know what i mean i don't know
it's gonna be a good one but you know
sometimes people ah
i'm not entirely
you know i'm not entirely sure you
should you know oh yeah gayle's already
texting to check
but i'm going to go up there and come
back in the same
in the same day so you're going up there
on the 19th
yes and you're coming back on the 19th
yes
we're on i can do it
i just need to ride up there
i'll drive the homie and i'll wave to
you guys up in the private jet yeah no
come on you want to go or not yeah don't
don't that's your public about them
i'm in
i'll just cancel like
[ __ ] i gotta pull everything yeah
what do you have now what do you have
tonight
we'll
yeah i'm down all right yeah
yeah i'll probably stay up there though
cause you know i got some some family
there
i'll just see him for
but that's the stuff you know that's
what we're flying to uh san jose oh yeah
cool
it's like uh that did you know
like the music at the park they're
having war there and everybody
were there and everybody yeah
george lopez
yeah man so let's do that all right
grant you're not invited
i'll cancel my doctoral appointment well
the white dude the pilots will be white
for you that'll take your spot
you